alright ok so you can see the slides but
you can't see my speaker notes right
good
ok thank you so much let's see alright
ok so I don't have a partner to support
me today which is just fine I need to
learn how to do this on my own
so feel free if you see something from
your end that I need to fix or you can't
see something please let me know
I appreciate that health and feedback
think we have about let me see what we
have here have 8 participants that's
great Wow okay so we have Brian from
Chicago muy dean from India Charles from
London
Google Mira great Diane I apologize if
I'm not pronouncing your name correctly
from Saudi Arabia Tanner from Turkey Wow
all over the globe great thanks so much
for joining
okay I'm gonna miss okay great all right
so we're gonna go ahead and get started
the car where where are you joining us
from today
[Music]
all right okay all right well let's go
ahead and get started and I'm going to
go ahead and admit people as they come
in here there are some new security
features that we're dealing with here
but you're good all right
okay I apologize for a little bit of
delay getting started okay so I am Diane
Burk hest
greetings to all of you from around the
globe
this is exciting thanks for joining in
today I'm gonna spend we have quite a
bit to cover today so I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on telling you about
me because you can see my slide here my
biography but that main two things that
I've done in my life
and I'm doing now as I spent about 35
years in human resources both in the
private and public sector and so the
topic of change is near and dear to my
heart one of the reasons I selected it
for today it was both a struggle a
challenge and its success for me and my
career in dealing with change and
helping employees understand changes and
and what I've done most recently I
actually retired early about two years
ago three years almost three years ago
and I've been coach for about five years
and so no I thought there are quite a
few quite a few webinars up there right
now about the köppen 19 so that is going
to serve as the backdrop for our
discussion today I'll be referring to
that quite often but we don't have to
just talk about that because obviously
there are all kinds of changes unreal
related to the puppet 19 thank goodness
right so but as I've been coaching my
clients lately and the students at
Udacity I've just been noticing what's
been going on with them and with others
around me and I realized that the
magnitude of changes that we're all
experiencing is so huge even one would
say unprecedented right now you've heard
that word before recently alright so I
thought it'd be helpful just a minute I
think we have some I'm going to ask you
to mute yourself if you would please um
just to avoid the the extra noise until
you speak that would really help me if
you don't mind I probably can't take
care of all the logistics here by myself
today I'm going to try but anyway I
thought it'd be helpful to have a
conversation about all these changes
we're facing and really you you may
already know about change process theory
and the science behind our and the
psychology behind change processes but I
thought it'd be good to remind ourselves
about the impact of change particularly
when it's involuntary something we
didn't want or asked for and well you
may be aware of all the science or
psychology you may not have thought
about it as consciously lately and so I
thought it would be good for us too let
me see I'm gonna mute everyone and you
are I'm gonna mute everyone right now
that you can unmute yourself if you want
to say something and I hope you will in
just a bit
so there are many models out there to
explain change management the concept of
change and the steps that we go through
whether we have changed inflicted upon
us or whether it's a situation where we
invite change into our lives which we do
quite often right sometimes we desire to
make some kind of change so oh just a
second
covered myself up there organizations
spend a lot of time and resources on
managing change you know it's critical
to their focus to bring people along and
to help their employees and the
community members respond to change
effectively so that they can get things
done right and so they want those
changes to be successful and what I want
to do today is kind of bring all of this
these concepts and these ideas and how
to make successful transitions down to a
more individual level and so we're going
to keep it pretty simple today I'm not
going to introduce a lot of theories or
too many models because many of you
already know what some of the factors
are that are at play but what's
important today is to really bring this
into our awareness and maybe give
ourselves a behind-the-scenes look at
what's really going on for ourselves and
others as we're dealing with not only
the coab in nineteen changes but all the
other changes that we face day in and
day out in our lives okay so the problem
what I want to do today is be more
intentional think about this consciously
dissect it think about how these
principles are applying to each of us as
we work through all these changes okay
so that's enough introduction let's get
on with it all right okay
I'll try to pay attention to the chat
and if you need something please feel
free to and
unmute yourself or or if you can't see
my slides let me know that so let's get
this conversation started what drew you
to attend this today and let's for this
can I ask you to unmute yourself and
speak so I can hear you and this will
this will be more fun for all of us if
it's not just me talking I guarantee to
you that Charles yes mom I think I'm
just curious off I've done training with
Udacity recent
visualization so I'm also in the career
change with that so I was just testing
to see if I can pick up some tools to
help that transition great great so glad
to hear your ear on today
okay who else why did you sign up for
this hi everyone I was immersed in
Netherlands for master's program this
crisis also the financial crisis coming
along with this
I couldn't pursue I couldn't go to study
there this year so I changed all my
plans and also my career plans have been
affected I'm trying to find an optimal
way out of this thing so I can
successful career afterwards okay great
the car thank you for sharing all right
who else tell me why you're here today
good morning everyone my name is karma
Soto I'm here to learn tools that can be
helpful for when I'm applying jobs
because most jobs are either being
cancelled or I don't have the
qualification so hopefully I can learn
something that can help me okay all
right
thank you so much for sharing that okay
all right okay so let's go forward um if
you want to still weigh in on why you're
here today
please feel free to do that in the chat
I'm gonna mute everybody again just to
keep the noise level down but feel free
to unmute yourself if you'd like to
speak I invite you to engage today
I forgot to say where I'm from calling
from I'm I'm on in Flagstaff Arizona in
the United States okay so it's early
morning here in Flagstaff and it's gonna
be a beautiful day so anyway what we're
going to talk about today is so so some
of the things that the three of you
mentioned we are going to talk about I
would say this is going to be more of a
soft skills approach to changing as
opposed to a I see a question from
Charles I'll have to answer that at the
end Charles as opposed to a kind of a
detailed here's you know how to get the
skills I need to make that change that's
actually a really good question I think
the last person who spoke I didn't catch
your name
for a coaching session so if you have a
coaching session available I recommend
you sign up with one of the coaches to
talk through that we're going to really
look at some of the theory and process
behind change successful change
management and again the point of this
is to kind of recognize what's going on
with each of us and others be more
supportive okay so today we're going to
talk about some of the changes you're
facing and what's going on because at
any given time we're dealing with
multiple changes at the same time right
and then one of them just one of the few
things that comes up when we're dealing
with change is we tend to resist okay
before we can move to acceptance which
is the ideal goal we typically resist
what's happening to us and I what's
interesting is we even do this when we
ask for the change ourselves if we're
making a career change let's say that
maybe we even got a promotion and it was
a desire change we're have a different
title we're making more money we still
tend to resist certain element
the change that's happening in our role
so that's why we talk about these things
okay so it's important also to note that
we are not alone in these changes and
how they're impacting us what we were
going through is absolutely perfectly
normal and each of us is dealing with
this in our own unique way okay we work
through the process of resisting
awareness acceptance all at different
paces okay so what you are feeling and
what others are feeling no matter where
you are in this process of transitioning
is perfectly normal so I want you to
really take that to heart and understand
that there's no right or wrong place to
be whenever you're experiencing
transition and change okay so we're
going to talk a little bit about the
changes the stages of transition today
and we're going to talk about how we
develop resilience okay so it really
resonated with me that the magnitude of
changes that's going on just with the
combin 19 is so major it's been
inflicted upon us it's not something we
asked for it's not even it's not
something we've wanted all the efforts
to thwart the virus and protect
ourselves and others have such a
far-reaching impact that most of us
could not have predicted it and it leads
to so many other one change leads to so
many other changes in our lives so if
you and others are feeling out of sorts
around all of this it is no wonder okay
just know that you're in good company
okay and then finally we're going to end
up today talking about how we can use
our current and past experiences
the most painful experiences that come
to us through change to be more
resilient for the future okay so any
comments before we move on
okay so here's why I need you to unmute
please and tell me about the changes you
are facing just give me the quick one or
two words about the changes and make if
if you have something related to career
and then something related to the rest
of your life please share that and it
doesn't even have to be related to Kovac
19 so just give me the one or two words
associated with the two changes that are
going on in your life changing work
environment work environment great
anything else for you change in physical
activity like being looked on right
right
wow that's big for a lot of people what
else is what other changes you're going
on race in my career an appraisal this
month so there might be as pretty more
from me so that's a change okay I think
that again you got a raise yeah yeah
great congratulations
and when it else did you say so there
might be expecting more and how can I
give them my best oh I see and this is
not waiting all right everyone's
speaking great congratulations the rest
of my team so you got a raise which is
great news um but you're thinking they
may be expecting more from you right
there's right now left that makes it
they probably are so that's an example
of what we talked about what I talked
about earlier is you know good change
leads to other things maybe that aren't
so comfortable what else what else is
going
for some of you out there the
environment and working from home
working from home how many how many of
you I always wanted to work from home
more and now you're you're either loving
it or you're hating it right very yeah
yeah how's it going for you it's
difficult cuz I have like my parent and
so if they need something there's no
they have easy eye disease could just
not endure it is no like there's no
boundaries right no boundaries easy
access lots of interruptions not so easy
to focus right right okay I see summit I
see Blanca in the chat she's a recent
graduate moved to the US and suddenly
have to come back to Mexico oh okay
that's hard right you Wow okay alright
okay alright so let's go ahead and move
on so the other day as I was putting
this presentation together I was just
thinking about all the things that were
happening to us and I was trying to
learn how to do work clouds and here's
my work Club okay we're not gonna spend
a lot of time on it these were the words
that came up for me in that moment
related to the cove at 19 so anyway it's
not by any means complete but see I
learned something new while I was
staying at home and working on my
presentation so hey I thought I'd share
that with you okay so let's move on why
do we resist change what are your
thoughts
well I guess because it's it's difficult
so you know it it requires you know
commit to the change and to adapt that's
for a lot of people resists change right
Charles right it's definitely it's
difficult it's not easy to make a change
and as I said it's difficult even than
the best of changes for most of us right
even the things we want and we ask for
are not so easy and we'll talk a little
bit about why that is what else who else
has a thought about why we resist change
Thank You Charles we're in our we're in
our comfort zone du génie we're outside
of our comfort zone Moy Dean see that in
the chat but that's exactly right we're
we're in it in an area that we're not so
comfortable right so we're resisting
change what else who else has a thought
about why we resist change like I'm just
keeping something else dire Nathan no
one else it you know there's the unknown
as well just you know frightened by the
change because you don't know how it
will impact you I guess and and that's
like a change manager speaking so change
initiative it's making sure that people
understand how will impact them before
they come up with you know views and I
think if we relate because it people are
you know looking at what's gonna come
next and how it's going to impact their
life but actually no one is able to
answer that question so that's why the
change is even scarier right absolutely
so you gave me a three pronged answer if
not more that's great Charles
so there's uncertainty how long is it
going to last what's going to look like
there's fear you talked about fear right
and then
this unknown what the world so unknown
an uncertain tear a little bit similar
but absolutely this is why these are
some of the reasons why we resist change
and then Brian says on the chat we have
to admit to ourselves already not as
great as we thought we were and that
comes up often yeah career changes and
you know that's a big one for people in
transition in their careers promotion is
often times where that one comes up I
had that happen to me in some of my
promotions I in the progress of my
career is it's sometime the realization
that I didn't do certain things as well
as I thought I would and that I needed
others to be competent in that area
because I was it was not a strength of
mine and so now that's a big one Brian
thank you for mentioning it what else
anything else
losing losing money our jobs also as
well as our habits that we have built
and which is so we will see that is
something that we feel we are losing
something they're building yeah
absolutely
is it hammer oh I see your name right no
it's Jonah
it's like John you can simply call me
John if you like okay John and John
thank you so much so I'm moving on to
the next slide absolutely no loss that
you talked about you know money loss of
John perhaps the threat and I'll just
add one more the threat to our health
right to potential threat to our health
or threat to our financial stability and
then you mentioned another one we're
creatures of habit we like routine and
we
order in our lives most of us and so the
change brings about you know a loss of
our routines someone mentioned earlier
the work environment has changed for
many of us our physical fitness is being
threatened because we're not able to go
to the gym or work out like we did
before so there's all this uncertainty
and and loss of order right so it feels
like chaos sometimes ok so let's talk
about a few others thank you John and
Charles and Brian and others for helping
me with this slide yes we talked about
the surprise earlier this was a surprise
to most of us we might have had some
sense that this could happen somewhere
in our lifetimes but but most of us were
surprised by this the next one on my
slide number 4 is the ability to adapt
that's another reason we resist change
is we're not and it kind of gets at what
Brian said some changes are things that
challenge our knowledge our skills and
we're not sure we're up to that
challenge right certainly people who've
not may be done zoom meetings had to
learn new ways of communicating with
others and how to do you know get brush
up on technology people who are just
used to going into the workplace every
day in and talking with their colleagues
now they have to figure out their
computer and so there are all kinds of
things like that so anyway all right and
then what about the extra of work and
effort what are you guys experiencing
there
if we just use to information the access
to information because if typically if
you work in an organization there is a
big change you probably wouldn't know
who to speak to going forward to find
that information can generate additional
work right right absolutely Charles what
else other extra work and effort with
the backdrop of Kovan 19 what's come up
for you guys
mobility in terms of going to the
supermarket getting items is more
difficult now you have to have a lot of
pages you have to wait in line yeah
absolutely
sometimes we're wiping off the groceries
before we put them away right lots of
that flavor okay all right and then the
other one after that is is one change
leads to another mom what's an example
of that we make one change and it leads
us to another change any any thoughts
about that okay so we're trying to
protect ourselves here's one let me see
if I could work through this we're
trying to protect ourselves our help
and in doing so it changes how we
interact with people that social
distancing thing so it's not just the
threat to our health but now it changes
the whole our whole social interaction
piece that might be one example and then
that there's another one connected to
that that I've experienced in terms of
just I have to think through
lutely everything more than once lately
when you're thinking about you know the
fact that somebody might be visiting and
maybe you are trying to stay more
socially isolated you have to think
through how to communicate with that
person in a way that doesn't put them
off or offend them and not challenge
their or come across like you're judging
them so there's all of this thing that's
intertwined okay all right so in the
spirit of stayin on the agenda I'm going
to move on certainly we can circle back
to this if you have other things you
want to say thank you thank you all
okay I'm gonna lock all right
okay so transition is the way that we
successfully move through the change
process and I chose a model that I think
is pretty simple for today and it is
William bridges model he was a famous
author speaker and organizational
consultant and he emphasized that
understanding transition is the key to
succeed in making effective change
he said that transition is psychological
process and adapting to change and that
it consists of three phases so we're
going to talk about each one of these
phases stage one how has this shown up
for you lately the ending losing and
letting go phase anyway and yeah I can
probably put my finger on one of two of
those feelings that you know before
recently you know on that so I think
that's a good example
sadly in terms of you know the
uncertainty I guess anger
as well you know yeah right
right okay and you actually highlighted
something I wanted you all to look at on
the slide what I've listed here some are
feelings some are thoughts and some are
actions are behaviors and that's going
to be important in a little bit when I
show you one of the tools that I'm
sharing with you so so there are
feelings of uncertainty there are
thoughts of you know a kind of denial
this isn't really happening and when
we're thinking about change we often go
through an introspective process of
evaluating what's important to us what
are our core values and what's our
belief systems around that and certainly
with the Cova 19 this has come up for
many of us you know what's our moral
obligation here you know what what's the
most important thing to us you know
we've had to make choices in this time
that that it's really challenged us to
put priorities in place and think about
our values and what's the most important
thing and even though we think this
might be a good thing or not the köppen
19 but some of the changes that come
from that and I certainly heard people
say that there have been positive things
these are thoughts that can impact us
and then that leads us to certain
actions or behaviors some people during
this stage might be reserved on taking
actions they might just be some or and
it might look like paralysis or they
might seem like drawn right others of us
might be researching talking to others
sorting out how we think about the
change so there's all kinds of things
going on in this stage okay all right so
the next stage stage number two is what
William bridges called the neutral zone
some of the feelings we might have going
on here as we might be resentful our
morale might be low the action that
results from morale being low oftentimes
as I'm not it's productive I might feel
stuck and another action is I might be
bouncing back and forth I said between
stage 1 and 3 I might actually be
bouncing back and forth between all
three stages and oftentimes we will we
remain skeptical about that so talk to
me how has this resonated with you how
many of you have felt like you've been
in the neutral zone recently and what
has that looked like for you all right
go ahead my team okay okay so I have
been always hearing that we should do
side projects to show to hone our skills
and where daily we should do any some
side projects so that's not that was not
I'm not having consistency with that so
that's what that's it's a lot of change
for me to have because usually it's best
to see my side projects being every day
there on the kick tap so I can't make it
every day though that's well that's what
I change that I'm always looking for
okay so a lack of consistency and
working on your side projects did I hear
that correctly okay yes okay sure sure
what else John now I think that most of
us are already in the second stage
because here we are already getting used
to the change but I personally not true
sometimes the
I'm doing the right thing to go out of
this crisis I'm not sure if I'm doing
the right things that will help me most
in in a longer time I'm not sure about
it right we start to question ourselves
right we're real stuff skeptical in and
part of that is some of those other
words we talked about before and you
know there's an uncertainty even with
your careers it's hard to know right now
what's the job market gonna look like
and you know this could be a good thing
and a bad thing but with this virus
there are some things are changing daily
some of the rules are changing around
all kinds of and policies for businesses
and so what does that look like when
things get back to what they're calling
the new normal we don't even know what
the new normal is going to be and what
and you know am i spending time on
something now that's not going to help
me in the future so yeah absolutely
if we are questioning ourselves a lot
during these times and it doesn't just
relate to should I stay home or not stay
home it's broader than that as you
brought up okay anyone else on that
stage to neutral zone amides more around
like below it's every day I watch it
like a motivational video to keep my
morale up but some days are harder than
others
sure sure you're feeling up and down and
and and that's stage one and and you're
doing your best and good for you you try
to watch something motivational positive
and uplifting and some days it works at
something some days they've got that
right right no it's a car that's great
absolutely don't worry have you guys
been noticing what's going on with other
do you think consciously about the fact
that if this is happening to you it's
happening with others as well and most
of you thinking that way yes for me
usually I try to reach a take a
particular day of the week in his try
reach out to others and see how they're
doing great great that's really helpful
and and it helps too because tensions
are high so when you have maybe you're
stuck at home with family of some of you
are and and you know you see reactions
that are sort of off-the-wall something
unexpected and it helps to kind of bring
this into consciousness and say okay
well I'm not sure why they did it that
way or why they said that or wiving
lashed out but but I have to recognize
they're going through these stages of
change and transition just like I am and
that was their reaction so anyway that's
one of the reasons I wanted to talk
about this today it's just to be more
supportive as the car said and they know
a lot of you are doing that to reach out
and talk to others okay so so moving on
the next the final stage according to
bridges model is new beginnings but you
know each person moves through these
stages at a different pace it's not a
linear and straight-line progression
we're going to move back and forth each
one of us require something different to
help us get through this and you know
when you look at the things on the new
beginning slide this is a time when some
of us start to feel more positive a
little bit more optimistic we might even
see good opportunities and we certainly
have seen that with the disco
mid-nineteen there there are going to be
things that are better at the end
because of this and when we start to see
that we can know that hey we're starting
to move into this final stage we're
starting to get to a place where we can
accept this change a little bit better
we start to change our expectations
right which helps us again that's kind
of a nice cycle when we start to change
our expectations we start to get less
disappointed when something doesn't go
the way we expect but when we reform our
expectations that actually helps us and
we're starting to look towards the
future feel more stable more energetic
and it just has a has a fresher feeling
of moving forward so okay but as you can
see just by talking through this model
and all the things that are going on if
you get to the end of the day and you're
feeling drained and exhausted emotional
frustrated you know this is to be
expected it's not uncommon and sometimes
it helps us to just be a little easier
with ourselves and others when we when
we recognize this fact okay so what can
we do about all this okay
so so one thing you're all doing here
today as you signed up for this webinar
some of you been participating in other
zoom or webinars or motivational
programs because you're seeking to
understand what's happening we're
talking today about the research behind
change process and one of the reasons
we're doing that is to get a better hold
on on what's happening to us
and the next bullet talks about seeking
out information and facts that's really
important during this time to kind of
isolate thoughts and all of the you know
sort out what's special and what's not
factual what's known and what's not
known and you know in order to be more
patient with ourselves and have empathy
and show support for others I think it's
helpful to realize that this will pass
that this is a temporary situation and
that even though right now everything
seems like
hot day if you're not from the US I
think this is a u.s. legend where the
groundhog comes out of his hole on
February 2nd thereabouts and looks at a
shadow and if think if he sees a shadow
there's going to be six more weeks of
winter
and so and I probably didn't get that
exactly right
but hopefully some of you know what I'm
talking about with the groundhog day and
so many people have said it feels like
Groundhog Day we're going through the
same thing day after day the good news
about that is you can actually stop
thinking about long-term for now with
regard to this code in nineteen and all
the things associated you can just think
about things that this is a day by day
and that the decision you make today may
not apply tomorrow so for some of us
that kind of helps so the other thing
that's helpful is to not worry so much
about your grand plans it's great if
you're a person who has as good at
setting goals and and your execution is
great and you're able to move make great
progress normally right now what's
really important is making steady
progress meaningful actions that you can
take to regain a sense of control and
move forward on a particular goal of
project you do with yourself don't
necessarily take them in sequence look
at your list break it down in the
smallest bite and decide what can I do
today what can i what will I actually be
able to accomplish sitting and make some
progress towards that action okay so I
mentioned that we're going to talk about
thoughts feelings and actions because I
highlighted some of those thinking
feeling action words on the slides about
the stages and I don't know if you've
seen this model
before this is actually called the
cognitive triangle and it has to do with
the inner relationship of our thoughts
feelings and behaviors it's a concept
used in behavior change process or
otherwise known as cog in cognitive
behavior therapy
I think the scholars behind that
research are last names
Ellis and Bek I don't know too much
about that actually but the point I want
to bring up here is that our thoughts
can influence our feelings and actions
our actions can influence our thoughts
and feelings and our feelings can
influence our actions and thoughts so
it's all interconnected and by changing
just one we can influence the other so
this is one of the tools I want to leave
you with today and that is that we can
just focus on one of these areas if
we're stuck ok and and the other concept
I want to share with you is that
thoughts are just thoughts we think
thousands and thousands of thoughts
every day and some of them we don't even
really pay attention to or we dismiss
them as blue wow that was weird where
did that thought come from I invite you
to practice that more often with the
thoughts that you do pay attention to we
oftentimes pay attention to thoughts as
if they are factual and they are real
and that often can drag us down it can
lead us to a place where our feelings
and and our actions
start to come from our thoughts even if
they're not factual or not even very
rational so I'm going to give you a
quick example given the time that where
we're at of how this played out with me
so with this koban 19 we're trying to
socially distance and we're worried
about age categories and whose most
vulnerable and so one day
have this thought actually several days
I'm never going to see my grandkids
again okay and I didn't even really
think too much about that thought I
didn't say to myself well that's not
factual that's not rational right away
my feelings I became very sad I had a
lot of deep emotion around that and you
know I just started to get feeling
somewhat desperate and in terms of the
action that I took I sort of felt like I
couldn't take any action it's like but I
was sort of in a panic and a desperation
motive and I was you know being HR
person that I am I always want to fix
things right and so I was trying to
figure out okay what could I do right
now to take care of this what can I got
to fix this this can't be happening okay
so what I did with that is I I realized
okay settle down um the idea that I'm
never gonna see my grandkids again it's
not only not is it rational it's not a
fact okay and so what that led me to was
a different thought and the thought was
this I'm not gonna see them for a while
until it's safer and right now we don't
know when that is okay and what that did
to my feelings is it gave me a much more
manageable emotion not so sad it was
more of a longing and a looking forward
to the day when I get to see them again
okay and then in terms of action this is
what's really nice is it actually
allowed me to do something realistic I
decided that okay now that I realized
it's just going to be temporary what can
I do right now that's really important
and this brought in some of the things
we talked about earlier sort of a
evaluating that's really important to me
well it's really important to meet it
for them to know that since they're
young that I'm not ignoring them that
I'm not just busy and not seeing them do
I wrote them a letter and I talked to
them it was a very short letter and I
figured they don't get letters too often
and so um
would be really cool for them to get a
letter in the mail they're stuck at home
they're not at school and so that was an
effective action that was appropriate
for the time so that's just one example
of how you can use this model to change
your behavior your feelings and your
thoughts and get in a place where you
can feel a lot better so just remember
thoughts are just thoughts you can make
a choice whether to accept thoughts as
that we're true if there's evidence
behind those thoughts then maybe you
want to pay more attention to them but
thoughts can pass if you let them and
thoughts are just thoughts they're not
facts okay all right any comments before
we move to result move on okay so the
point that I want to make here is that
we can all emerge stronger and more
resilient this is what's on the other
side when we make the transition
successfully we can come out stronger
and you know this already I'm stating
the obvious but what does it mean to
some of you when I say resilient tell me
what that is we might have a thought
about what what we're after when we say
resilient it's almost like a stamina you
know being able to overcome any
challenges so instead of making you
stronger and making you figure in that
sense you know right right more stamina
for the future stronger up for the
challenge
bounce back easier all of those things
right okay
all right so well you actually like
bounce Parker you know a full couple of
years ago I read that book called bounce
back which is actually a really good
book oh great bounce back there's a book
out there guys all of you I haven't read
that I will look for it bounce back
great book on resilience might be a good
thing
you right now read a book on resilience
anyway I saw this boat as I was making
this presentation resilience is very
different than being numb resilience
means you experience you feel you feel
you hurt you fall but you keep going
this is a scholar that studies at the
University of Madison Wisconsin I don't
I will mess up her name yeah can't even
see it right now Yasmine but we talked a
lot today about feelings of pain and
your experiences maybe we didn't get
into the pain so much but your you
shared your experiences and you know
again my point to you today is this is
all very normal and you're still here
and you showed up today so that you know
we've been through some tough times
recently we will come out the other side
together and if things will be better in
some ways they will be different we will
adjust to the new normal but we'll still
be here you know hopefully all of us
most of us all of us and and so we need
to consciously work on building our
resistance and some of the ways we can
do this is shifting away from negative
thought patterns look for the silver
lining what's the opportunity I'm
hearing from some people that hey
they're sheltered at home they're stuck
with your family but the silver lining
of that is they've grown closer to their
children their partners their spouse
they've had time to spend with them that
they've never had before so there's all
kinds of ways to view the there's always
an upside and a downside and that helps
us reframe it for the future finding the
meaning and difficult situations you
know what is the purpose here you know I
shifted away from paying attention to my
health even my physical fitness perhaps
and I realized that what's most
important in these
perhaps is health and family and that
might be it for me it might be something
else for someone else so the meaning and
that for me might be these are the
primaries this is what's important
caring for others being sensitive to
what others are going through realizing
that I'm not everybody's on the same in
the same situation financially and what
a struggle that is and how can I reach
out and help others and then develop
your confidence you know this this tests
us times like these tests us but I think
if you'll think back in your life you'll
realize that you've been through some
pretty tough times personally or in your
career and and it's those things that
cause us to emerge stronger and I would
say one intentional thing you can do to
develop your confidence is always try to
do something out of your comfort zone I
think Brian mentioned earlier that part
of the reason we feel uncomfortable with
change or we resist it is we're being
asked or OS muy muy dean I think that's
a gap and we're being asked to do things
that are out of our comfort zone but you
can intentionally choose to do this this
helps you become more resilient it helps
you become stronger and then the last
one that I want to move to before we
wrap up is how do you reframe your past
successes and use them to become
stronger for the future and more
successful so I like this visual and
even the quote that's kind of fitting
but I'll leave you with some questions
and I'd really like you to take these
questions away today and I'd like you to
spend some time maybe some quiet time
thinking about this this comes up often
in my coaching sessions with people who
are trying to make transitions and now
what passed like here's the first
question what past life experience have
contributed most to your resilience what
past life experience has contributed
most to your resilience Mary answer that
absolutely if you're wanting to share I
love it thank you
sturdy for the engineering made me more
resilient because I lost the fear of
failure because I know other times the
failure comes in my head Santo I would
be confident that I will do my maximum
and leave the research whatever the
result may be so that has made a lot to
my confidence and I can also see that
work in my work working in my office
also Hey so so you in your study of
engineering you've lost the fear of
failure wow that's so powerful that that
has to thank you for sharing that
yeah you've been through it one time
before because you have lots of fear
around family when you started the
engineering studies I'm guessing and you
made it through it and so you know that
whatever challenge you face in the
future
that you will do your best you will give
it your maximum attention and you will
most likely be successful you are no
longer afraid of failing but for you
awesome Wow okay so so super anybody
else want to share
okay okay I hear somebody the car for me
for me those those physics those physics
kinematics it had calculus in it and I
took like three times I feel it
thank you I feel it twice and if anytime
I got happy oh wow so I reached max for
a lot of help and helped me overcome it
because after something twice you want
to give up but I didn't give up the
professor kid
pushing me and I passed it okay so dad
actually no this is perfect
this actually gives me the segue into my
next parts of the question so CarShare
exactly when he learned from that
experience of a failing calculus twice
and he didn't give up and he got help
cuz that's my next question what did you
learn from that experience and so it
sounds like you learned Sekar that don't
give up you can do it get help
accept help and you can be successful it
would not be accurate for you
yes great so that's the second part of
the question what did you learn from
that experience write that down and
think about that today and then the
final part of the question is what did
you do specifically that helped you be
successful and really the reason I'm
asking it that way is to just peel back
the onion a little bit more and break it
down into actual steps what were all the
things you did specifically that helped
you be successful so then I would put it
back on some car with that question and
say okay so when you want it to give up
how did you make it through that desire
to give up and you don't have to answer
me it's the karbix that i want to put
you on the spot you can if you like but
that's the that's why it's a three three
questions to ask yourself what did i do
specifically that helped me be
successful and then I guess there's
probably a fourth part of the question
and that fourth question
is how can I take all that I've learned
in my past success and apply it to what
I'm currently facing whatever that is
how can I take what I learned from my
past success and apply it in this
situation whatever the challenges that
you're facing okay so that's that's your
takeaway I hope today that this is this
is your action from the session today is
to I hope you were able to write down
those questions and think about that I
would ask you to maybe give yourself the
luxury of 10 to 15 quiet interrupted
moments uninterrupted moments and if you
know if it helps you to write down the
answers do that and this is a way you
can reframe for the future this can help
you become more successful and more
resilient in the future no matter what
it is you can take one life situation
and apply it to a different type of life
situation you can take something you
learned about relationships in your
personal life and apply it to a
situation in your career and vice versa
so that's the beauty of reframing okay
so we've come to the end of our time I
do I'm sorry we're just a little bit
over so if you have questions I'll keep
it open for a few minutes if I can it
doesn't expire you can ask me in the
chat and I'll try to get you some
answers
a final quote I ran into I just think
it's a somewhat powerful successful
people demonstrate their resilience
through their dedication to making
progress every day even if that progress
is marginal I think this was really
resonated with me today because right
now sometimes it's hard to focus on
major accomplishments but doing
something meaningful every day that
brings you towards your goal is really
helpful and even if it's not
related to the particular goal doing
something meaningful that is satisfying
can help you get through these tough
times okay well thank you so much
yeah actually Diane if you might need
shipping on the you know inspiring quote
there is that very famous quote from Sun
Tzu that says a journey of a thousand
miles starts with a single step
a journey of a thousand miles starts
with a single step
absolutely Charles thank you for sharing
that that is so true
all right well thank you all for
engaging I'm sorry I went a few minutes
over I wish you well please stay safe
take care of yourselves and others and
again thanks for all of the
participation I've enjoyed getting to
interact with you guys today so thank
you very much Diane so just on the sign
though I'm quite curious about the
medals behind just explained it's
actually my father-in-law's medals he
was in World War two oh wow that's very
impressive yes yes we treasure down
absolutely
great thank you for asking thank you
there all right
bye-bye take care